Governor Newsom
his ex-wife Jennifer Newsome
Jennifer siebel Newsom I think that is
her name yes she called me and she set
up a meeting with me to meet her
somewhere in Brentwood and I actually
went and I got very like creeped out and
I saw her sitting where our sister meet
her and I looked at her and I I turned
around and went back into my car and
drove away she wanted to meet me she
reached out to me
before we completely lose the the
political part yeah the Newsome the
Newsome part rather so Newsome yeah no
it all sort of fits but I know you've
got something you wanted to talk about
about Newsome specifically yes Dave
thank you for reminding me
oh I feel like Hal 2000 yes Dave
no Dave sorry Dave no Dave sorry Dave
that's strange so yes Governor Newsom
his uh ex-wife Jennifer Newsome
Jennifer siebold Newsom I think that is
her name yes she called me and she set
up a meeting with me to meet her
somewhere in Brentwood and I actually
went and I got very like creeped out and
I saw her sitting where our sister meet
her and I looked at her and I I turned
around and went back into my car and
drove away she wanted to meet me
it's just about uh six months before the
New York Times article on Weinstein that
I set up broke
okay and she called me on behalf of a
theranos board member the uh lawyer for
a long time lawyer of Hillary and Bill
and um Clinton and Weinstein one David
Boyce so this woman I don't know some
blonde lady named with the last name of
Newsome cold calls me and he's like
David Boyce wants to know what it would
take to make you happy
six months before the Weinstein story
what it would take to make you happy
which you took as for those that might
be playing along a little bit slowly
absolutely nothing would make me happy
you falling off the planet David Boyce
and your whole company if you all follow
us the planet I would be happy since you
cannot do that
I will remain unhappy with you and you
shall deal with my displeasure
but they're scary these are operators
they're tied into SDK Knickerbocker
they're tied into Hillary they're tied
into Nancy Pelosi this is all back door
[ __ ] for their gain and we're tired
of it we're suffering people are dying
not just because stupid ass covid but
because their [ __ ] system is [ __ ]
killing us and I've had it and I think a
lot of us had so now it's time to go
from feeling I feel this is all [ __ ]
to fact it is all [ __ ] and vote
Larry Elder cause why why the [ __ ] not
what have you got to lose how's it going
people how's your systemized Society
working for you try something different
might as well
there's my pitch
like a pro like the best campaign like
you know I just like for me like I used
to volunteer years ago at a place called
Covenant House and I never did it with
cameras and I would go and I would speak
to homeless runaway uh trans kids which
you know um because I was taken in by
them when I was a homeless 13 year old
that's who raised me they were like my
mother's right so I always felt like I
would pay the favor and I knew that
state-run therapy could not help them in
the way that I could because I don't use
language the same way most people do and
I'm not scared so when a kid when the
therapist would say this goes together
with this how did that make you feel
and they're like they're like [ __ ] they
the hard shell comes up that doesn't
make me feel anything and and I because
I'm not bound by state laws or regular
normal ways conversing which is why I'm
effective I believe is is simply because
I said really
that would hurt me so badly
I would feel so betrayed and abandoned
if the person I came here with abandoned
me on the first day left me to rot on
the streets I would that would like
shake my faith in humans and everything
else and I feel like that is what the
state of California needs to say to
Gavin Newsom on Election Day you're
betrayed us you've heard us you and your
whole type because you are one in a long
line of lizards and we don't want you
anymore I like lizards I like real
lizards but I don't like the fake
lizards so clean house you can do it go
to the polls do it for me because I'm
not gonna
he got this
just to be totally clear here Gavin
newsom's wife
wanted to sit or wanted to sit down with
you which then turned out to be on the
phone where she said what can Harvey
Weinstein's lawyer do to make this story
go away what's the connection to Gavin
newsom's wife why why was it that she
was the one that was calling you
mystified me too because they tried
every way they could they tried every
single way they could to get to me I
mean my literary agency Duprey Miller
who I hired to represent me to Shepherd
and protect my book from Weinstein Jan
Miller
um it's a big literary firm and they
were secretly exposed they were exposed
for secretly working with Weinstein the
entire time they're supposed to be
protecting my book they were exposed to
the New York Times for that and when I
met her this Jan Miller woman she was
bragging about like giving a fifteen
thousand dollar plate dinner for David
Boyce and Bill and Hillary that night in
Dallas so you know do the math it's all
connected it is all connected one at a
time I am coming
yeah I mean that seems like a fairly big
scandal with an election coming in four
days basically
just like another and
literally the governor's wife calling me
to you know basically shut me up with
money about the biggest sex scandal of
all time
rapist and I load the media they're
always like disgrace
he was an Indigent black rapist would
you say disgraced
disgrace homeless rapist no he's a
convicted serial rapist let's just say
it we can all be adults it wasn't
pleasant it wasn't fun they really built
a beast in me and all I ever wanted to
do in my whole life Dave was lay under
tree at night in the grass and look for
owls
I know I know I know that's true with
you you love the owls and we've got this
very bizarre owl connection we both have
owls hanging outside our houses not in
part two but so I said the things if
there are people out there that can go
in on this and and work it out and
expose more yes they're all part of it
and this whole like Oprah saying like or
Meryl Streep or uh Gavin Newsom oh we're
in our Ivory Tower we just didn't know
anything about it we're too fancy for
that that's just those you know the
little actresses they wore short skirts
they deserved it no this was a machine
this is a machine it has many many
tentacles one tentacles the human
trafficking arm of it right he had a
daily appointment for rape 1 pm around
1pm every day daily appointment for many
years anywhere there's a film festival
and it takes his protection I introduced
Hillary
at Aussie Fest about three something
years ago in Central Park so it's like
it was like a rock concert for speakers
so they got me up there and at this
point I just really found out how deep
involved in in this whole thing like
that camp was right
um and that it hadn't really been
publicly outed yet by me or anybody
and so they said okay so you're gonna
introduce Hillary and I'm like great
I got this
so the last thing I said to this like it
was like a rock concert right I'm up
there
and I said and the last thing I will say
to you all today
Harvey Weinstein was protected by the
Democratic party welcome to the stage
Hillary Clinton
and this Collective Northern liberal
gasp
like and suddenly I was literally like
yanked off stage they wouldn't let me go
backstage to get my purse I'm walking
out of Central Park I see her like Town
Car go by see the hair like you know in
profile and I just see her face like in
profile
and I was like nailed it
wow but I can I serve I serve why
because I was born to is there video of
that I mean that that oh my God it's got
to be somewhere and maybe let's uh I
looked for it on their site but of
course no you know they take down
everything
but it like somebody out there has that
video I was certainly I certainly did it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell